millions de cyclistes ont emprunté la
Loire à vélo en 2022 c'est le résultat
d'une enquête menée par de région
traversée par cette itinéraires le
centre Val de Loire et les Pays de la
Loire un succès sans précédent avec près
de 54 millions d'euros de retombées
économiques analyse d'un tourisme qui
fait la part belle à la lenteur et à la
nature avec Clémence d'OSC
des allées vite dans le camping de
Savonnières ce matin les cyclotouristes
sont partis aux aurores sur la Loire à
vélo reste Lucie son ami et leurs
enfants il se prépare à reprendre la
route le côté partir de chez soi en vélo
déjà c'est un côté agréable de dire
qu'on part en voiture de partir avec
vraiment le strict nécessaire aussi
c'est un côté on se sent plus léger quoi
on va dire bonne journée au revoir en
période estivale les cyclotouristes de
la Loire à Vélo représente 80% de la
clientèle du camping sur place tout est
prévu pour leur simplifier la vie
l'établissement et labellisé accueille
vélo donc ce sont des locatifs à
destination principalement des cyclistes
qui leur permettent d'avoir accès à
l'électricité de ne pas avoir à déplier
leur tente le soir ça leur permet aussi
d'avoir des abris en cas d'intempéries
on a aussi différents pôles sur le
camping avec des bornes de réparation
vélo des zones un peu de restauration où
on met en accès libre des frigos
micro-ondes et des petites tapes pour
pouvoir se poser se restaurer à l'abri
des infrastructures adaptées afin de
maintenir la bonne image de l'itinéraire
à vélo avec 54,5 millions d'euros de
retombées économique pour les
territoires caloriques en 2022 la
véloroute est un véritable enjeu
économique et touristique
investissement en moins de 3 ans
il est il se retrouve dans l'économie
locale il se retrouve pour dynamiser nos
petits commerces ils se retrouvent pour
dynamiser la location de vélo donc c'est
vraiment un investissement qui est
depuis quand même ces chiffres là ils
disent quoi ils disent que Centre-Val de
Loire et vraiment la première région du
tourisme à vélo cap sur un tourisme
interrégional et à taille humaine pour
le cyclotourisme tout roule et les
acteurs du territoire l'ont bien compris